[Music]
president obama a man so close to being
able to smoke again he can almost taste
those camels now his time in office is
almost done and while he's achieved a
great many things tonight we're gonna
look at one of his in arguable failures
i have ordered the prison at Guantanamo
Bay closed by early next year make no
mistake we will close Guantanamo prison
I still want to close Guantanamo as
president I have tried to close Gitmo I
will continue to push to close Gitmo
it's time to close Gitmo today the
department is submitting to Congress our
plan for finally closing the facility at
Guantanamo once and for all yes
Guantanamo Bay it's Obama's one that got
away which is a little odd considering
it's a place where literally no one can
get away so why has the president been
unable to close Gitmo well for a start
most people don't want him to according
to a recent poll 52% of Americans
believe it should remain open and there
are others who believe we should
actually be using it more in my opinion
the only problem with Guantanamo Bay is
there are too many empty beds and cells
there right now we should be sending
more terrorists there for further
interrogation to keep this country safe
as far as I'm concerned every last one
of them can rot in hell but as long as
they don't do that and they can rot in
Guantanamo Bay now now he's basically
saying there let's use Guantanamo Bay
like hell's waiting room and that is
problematic for two reasons first it's
arguably unconstitutional and second
hell's waiting room is already the
slogan of Henry Kissinger's bedroom
that's a fact that's just a fact and
look I can see I can see the reasons
that Guantanamo is appealing you get to
keep potentially dangerous people locked
up and far away but tonight I would like
to argue that there are even better
reasons for closing it forever
and let's just start with the practical
ones it's very expensive
Guantanamo cost four hundred and forty
five million dollars to run last year
which means we're currently spending
over seven million dollars per prisoner
per year but the costs obviously go way
beyond that
last year a UN Human Rights Council
conducted a review of the US and Gitmo
was some
a feature Iceland recommends the closure
of the Guantanamo prison and illegal
detentions in Guantanamo Bay immediately
close the Guantanamo Bay facility and do
all its best in order to close down the
Guantanamo facilities improve living
conditions in prisoners in particular in
Guam or investigate torture allegation
extrajudicial execution and other
violations of human rights committed in
Guantanamo yeah you got it right that is
Iran Sudan Libya and others lecturing us
about human rights abuses which is yeah
a little hypocritical maybe don't tell
us to eat healthy when you have a
what perrito in your mouth but
but it does seem like this is one of the
few things the entire world agrees on
it's basically Guantanamo is up
and yeah you know what
Kevin can wait let the man wait so how
did we get here
well Guantanamo's origins are basically
a series of weird circumstances and ad
hoc decisions for start we don't own it
it's a rental in in 1903 we struck a
deal with Cuba to lease the land for a
naval base and ever since we have mailed
them a check every year for four
thousand and eighty five dollars in rent
although as Fidel Castro once told a
film crew they've just been accumulating
in his desk I get it if you'd kiss those
chi-chi's they'll go yeah no not them
Anika no just think about that we've
barely been talking to Cuba we disagree
with their politics and yet every year
we send them checks for hilariously
small amounts of money
we're basically Cuba's grandparents
and this this unique arrangement means
that Guantanamo where telephones Legally
both America and not America or as one
White House official once called it the
legal equivalent of outer space which is
a bit of an exaggeration to be honest
some laws do apply up in space there's
the law of physics for example and the
law of attraction yes of course you
didn't really think Neil and Buzz did
not on the moon right oh they moved they
moved my friends
bill would deal with that this legal
limbo has been useful to us in the past
George HW Bush used Guantanamo to
involuntarily detained Haitian refugees
seeking asylum and Bill Clinton not only
continued that for a while he later used
it to hold Cuban refugees so the use of
Gitmo to store people was one of those
dicey legal workarounds in the 90s it
was right up there with Vanilla Ice's
explanation of why he didn't trip off no
problem man now now stashing those
refugees at Gitmo attracted significant
criticism at the time but when the war
on terror began we started doing the
exact same thing with terror suspects
even though right from the start donald
rumsfeld admitted it was far from the
perfect solution pastor told people
further reasons why use it why is it the
best place I Kylie characterized Montana
MoBay Cuba as the least worst place we
could have selected the least worst
place that is a rousing endorsement from
the worst worst Secretary of Defense of
all time
obvious problem with using Guantanamo in
the war on terror and people were
pointing it out at the time how do you
avoid the prospect of the US military in
fact being jailers for an indeterminate
period of time of people who have not
been charged what are you what are you
gonna do about it it is certainly the
the not the first choice of the
Department of Defense to be in the
business of detaining people for long
periods of time yeah it might not have
been his first choice but it was
inevitable because at a war on terror
isn't a traditional war where there's an
exchange of prisoners at the end we were
never going to accept a formal surrender
from the president of terror who I can
only assume is Willem Dafoe and now that
brings us to here here right now nearly
a decade and a half later and we are all
so accustomed to the very existence of
Guantanamo that news crews tore it like
it's a million dollar listing this is a
typical cell in camp five it meets all
American Correctional Association
standards this is about 95 square feet
of living space with about 80 feet of
unencumbered space one of the other
amenities available to the detainees is
a library of books magazines and
videogames the book that we have the
most in different languages would be the
Harry Potter series inmates are also
given art classes the results of which
are on display he's making it sound like
the world's least Jewish summer camp
nobody is although even the current
luxuries the prisoners get tend to carry
a chilling reminder of where they are
all prisoners use toiletries which
happen to have the brand names maximum
security oh come on a prison calling its
deodorants maximum security is a little
on the nose it'd be like a Holiday Inn
Express calling its complimentary lotion
tearful masturbation
that hit home a little too close to some
of you and before you think that those
library books provided an escape for the
inmates just listen to shocker
Armour who was released last October
after being held without charge for
nearly 14 years he found one particular
book less an escape and more a reminder
of where he was in a beggarly they got
an island in Harry Potter he says as
become where there's no happiness they
do you know they just suck all your
feelings out of you and you don't you
don't have no feeling anymore and truly
that's what I felt all the time is this
is as back on this is not from this
world you know because that's what they
tried you know they want to make you
feel English Wow
that is the saddest allusion to Harry
Potter I have ever heard and I say that
as a man who is often described as Harry
Potter if he aged like a president and
that's the point here no amount of
sugarcoating can cover up the reality of
what we have done at Guantanamo Bay
because in the early years interrogation
techniques included physical beatings
short shackling where are prisoners arms
and legs are shackled together for long
periods and hours and sometimes days of
repeated loud music which is horrendous
although sometimes that last technique
backfired because that same Harry Potter
loving inmate grew up loving American
rock music and would annoy the guards by
singing along and just listen to him
describe the one song that gave him the
most consolation I mean I'm sure
everybody would love one here because I
used to sing here al I used to because
the words I thought the words are fits
me the words makes me feel like yeah
it's me again which is the Whitesnake
it's here I go again
the go the worst goes here I go again on
my own going down the only Road I never
known like a drifter I was born to walk
alone because I know what it means to
walk alone in only street of dreams and
here I go again and it's too because
it's just dreams dreams that I will be
home one day dreams that I'll be free
dreams that content will be closed you
know you are miserable when you are
finding solace in a Whitesnake
song that is a group whose second most
inspirational lyrics are probably I know
you ain't a bad girl honey no matter
what the neighbors say it's just you
wear those skin tight dresses with your
g-string tunes to a pure poetry purest
poetry but we justify Gitmo and
everything we did inside it because we
were constantly reminded of one thing
these are not mere innocence these are
among the worst of the worst they are
bad guys these are the worst of the
worst these are the people who are the
bomb makers the bodyguards of Asama bin
Laden the financers that the plotters
the people who have been sent out to be
assassins to be a suicide bombers these
are the worst of the worst now the worst
of the worst is a big claim I can think
of at least one person who fits that
category and who is not in there and
that's because apparently he stills
working for the Today Show but who knows
but but what but while some detainees
some detainees like Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed have clearly earned that title
others have not because think about it
if they were really also terrible it's a
little shocking that we've released
seven hundred and ten detainees over the
years and leaked documents have since
revealed four out of 212 Afghans who
were there almost half were in the
assessments of US forces either entirely
innocent mere Taliban conscripts or had
been transferred to Guantanamo with no
reason for doing so on file and some of
the evidence against detainees was
surprisingly flimsy one I guess piece of
evidence that they would use to
determine I thought this was fascinating
Casio watches
well it
it's kind of a little bit arbitrary but
anybody who was wearing this particular
brand of Casio watch which was handed
out by al-qaeda to their fighters
because it was used as a timer for
setting off devices so anybody who
happened to have this very popular watch
on was immediately picked up and a lot
of them ended up in Guantanamo Bay
that's true if someone was caught
wearing this Casio watch that could be
used as crucial evidence and
incidentally that makes this the only
time in history anyone has actively
sought out a man wearing a Casio watch
look this is not to say that everyone in
Guantanamo is or was innocent and there
is justifiable concern that whenever we
release someone they might go on to
fight against us in fact the government
claims that nearly six percent of those
released under President Obama have been
confirmed to have read in insurgent or
terrorist activities and for those
released by the Bush administration it's
been 21% and while some argue those
numbers are inflated even if they are
they are not zero and that is why
politicians like Dick Cheney have taken
a hard-line position that we should not
let anyone go I'm more concerned with
bad guys who got out and released than I
am with a few that in fact were innocent
you're okay with that margin for I have
no problem as long as we achieve our
objective yeah but that is not
reassuring the only objectives Dick
Cheney has ever achieved have been
somehow serving as president
unofficially and managing to exist
without the need for a working heart so
so there are clearly sharp divisions
about what we should do with the
remaining population and you should know
there's actually not that many left
there are currently just 61 detainees
down there that's less than the number
of people in our audience right now some
of whom are arguably worse people than
some of the detainees you know they know
they
they know it it's an odd thing to clap
and and you might think well why doesn't
the president just put them on trial
figure out which ones are guilty and
then he can decide whether or not to
close it well it's just not that simple
because the 61 detainees fall into three
groups ten of them including Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed are having their cases
handled by a military commission that is
a legal process that we've basically
invented from scratch and it's so flawed
that of its eight convictions so far
four have been fully reversed on appeal
now another 20 of them are actually
slated for release but are waiting for
the State Department the intelligence
agencies and the Department of Defense
to agree on a country to send them to
and that leaves us with the trickiest
group the remaining 31 detainees who
have not been charged with a crime but
who are also not cleared to be released
and they are the real problem here
because even the president doesn't quite
know what to do with them there's gonna
be a certain irreducible number that are
gonna be really hard cases because you
know we know they've done something
wrong and they are still dangerous but
it's difficult to mount the evidence
than a traditional article 3 court more
so we're gonna have to wrestle a bit now
think about what he just said that is
the president a man who has taught
constitutional law suggesting that for
some detainees there is no clear path
toward a trial or an exit now it's a
group that the administration is called
the irreducible minimum which sounds
like the name of a band that was going
to call itself absolute zero but got
into a fight about it with their
pretentious theremin player
and if you're wondering why the
president says it's difficult to
announce the evidence what it means
there is in some cases there's not
enough of its and in others it was
obtained through torture and there is a
good reason that that is inadmissible
because people often say anything to
make torture stop if you gave me a
purple nurple for just 10 seconds I
would look you in the eye and swear that
my favorite cereal is grape nuts and and
I'm fairly sure that that cereals
original name was good-morning idiot eat
some cat litter so the point is how does
the president who has spent nearly a
decade promising to close Gitmo plan to
do that well it turns out it all depends
on what your definition of the word
close is closing Guantanamo at this
stage in the Obama administration view
is really moving Guantanamo to US soil
the idea is to pick up the last
detainees and move them to military
detention in the United States what we
call Guantanamo North yes Guantanamo
North or as I'm sure it will be called
once they build a wholefoods their Gitmo
no and look moving Guantanamo is not
closing it but even that is not going to
happen there's been relentless
congressional opposition to moving any
detainees to US soil and the people in
charge of Gitmo seem to be settling in
for the long haul and the reason we know
that is because a legal document from
last month showed the commander the
current commander there proposes
renovating their infirmary as it will be
beneficial to the continued care of the
aging population so there might well be
detainees that we scooped up as young
men who we think are guilty but who will
never get a trial and they will be there
until they die and at this point we all
have to ask ourselves are we okay with
that and remember it does seem that more
than half of us are but I would argue
that any potential risk in putting
detainees on trial losing that case and
having to release them is worth it for a
few important reasons first as it stands
we are ceding so much moral high-ground
that Vladimir Putin feels comfortable
saying things like this but then you
they once said that they would close
Guantanamo and what is it closed no
today there's still people there walking
in shackles that is just medieval
without a trial these people stay in
prison well just imagine can you imagine
if we did that here I can't wrap my head
around it
luckily here in Russia the people I do
not like just disappear for reasons well
supporters of Guantanamo argue that
closing it would be a sign of weakness I
would argue it's an act of strength just
listen to Lawrence Wilkins Wilkerson :
Powell's former chief of staff what do
we do with them do we leave them there
forever as an American citizen who is
not a coward
I'd be willing to release every one of
them tomorrow morning and face them on
the battlefield again if necessary but
we got a lot of cowards in this country
these days exactly when you see a bumper
sticker that says freedom isn't free
this is what that means standing up for
our highest ideals even when it requires
accepting a certain amount of risk and
when that bumper sticker was displayed
above a pair of red white and blue truck
nuts it's a good reminder that doing
something like that takes balls and and
there is actually one final thing to
consider here the concept of Guantanamo
represents an opportunity to operate
outside the boundaries of the law and
that is way too tempting a proposition
to have at the government's disposal
because well you might be someone who
trusts President Obama's judgment
remember he's on his way out now meaning
that the keys to Azkaban will be handed
over to whoever succeeds him and there
is still a possibility it's going to be
this guy we're going to keep as you know
Gitmo we're keeping that open and we're
gonna load it up with bad dudes we're
gonna load it up
a lot of bad dudes out there that's the
point
if we don't shut it down future
President Trump could theoretically
throw anyone he doesn't like into
Guantanamo and you might say well come
on he'd have to come up with some
pretext and it couldn't be an American
citizen but I would like to put it to
you that I've been talking this guy
for the better part of a year
[Applause]
you